the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of agon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
in House of the Dragon update video in
this new video I will be revealing some
exciting new information regarding house
saw the dragon's new season well my
friends it's Now official HBO is no
longer filming any more scenes for the
second season the second season of HBO's
hit series House of the Dragon starring
Emma Darcy Matt Smith and Olivia Cook
has finally reached the finish line of
its filming schedule at leaves in
studios after 5 and 1/2 months of
filming now they're handing over all of
their new footage for the editors and
special effects we're now one step
further to finally seeing what will
happen during the dance of the dragons
and House of the Dragon second season a
new article from variety also says HBO
is eager to take fans back to Westeros
for more backstabbing and incest with
the second season of House of the dragon
as they aim for a release during the
summer of 2024 they're also looking
ahead to a yet to be ordered third
season of The Game of Thrones series now
although HBO hasn't ordered a third
season yet we all know it's only a
matter of time before they do
considering House of the Dragon is
without a doubt one of their most
successful shows on the network as I'm
sure most of you already know House of
the Dragon had an incred L successful
first season and I believe the show will
only get bigger with each New Year it's
no secret Game of Thrones is back and
it's out for vengeance Justice and Fire
and Blood now before I get into any of
the new details during the filming of
House of the Dragon second season I have
to let all of you know about this
amazing new offer I'd like to thank the
sponsor of today's video Factor as
someone with an extremely busy schedule
who exercises daily and likes to eat
healthy Factor has been a game changer
for me now that I've been eating it
every day Factor makes meeting your
nutritional goals easier than ever by
delivering dietitian approved meals that
are fresh and never Frozen right to your
doorstep each meal is created by
Factor's Gourmet chefs using fresh
ingredients to help you feel your best
all day long now this time of the year
is always really busy for us and we
don't always have the time to cook a
healthy meal at the end of the day with
Factor you can skip the trip to the
grocery store and save time on having to
chop up ingredients or meal prepping and
what I love most is there's little to no
cleanup fact fresh never frozen meals
are ready in only 2 minutes so all you
have to do is heat enjoy then get back
to Smashing your daily goals Factor
really has something for everyone with
34 plus weekly flavored packed meals to
choose from with only 550 calories or
less one of my absolute favorites is the
fucili and ground pork Ragu it has the
best meaty and cheesy spaghetti mixture
and it also has some delicious roasted
green beans it's incredibly filling and
flavorful they also have Gourmet plus
options featuring amazing ingredients
like broccoli and truffle butter I'm
also really looking forward to the new
surf and turf steak and shrimp that is
coming soon you can choose to try their
Protein Plus meals with 30 or more grams
of protein in each serving and they have
45 plus add-ons including breakfast
items like apple cinnamon pancakes and
bacon and cheddar egg bites now if
you're too busy this fall to cook but
you still want to make sure you and your
family are eating well head to
factor75.com or click the link below and
use the code talking Thrones 50 to get
50% off your first first Factor box
again that's factor75.com and use the
code talking Thrones 50 to get 50% off
your first Factor box once again I have
to thank factor for sponsoring today's
video a very interesting message was
revealed by those who worked on the show
it's actually a glimpse of what we will
see happen during this second season
it's a message from Lis to King aegon
which says you have already written
yourself into Legend you survived dragon
fire this short note actually reveals a
major scene from the upcoming season
this is in reference to the dragon fight
aegon and Amon will have with rain East
Targaryen during the battle at rook's
rest their Three Dragons will light up
the night sky as House Targaryen fights
over the Iron Throne we've already seen
a lot of exciting and interesting images
from this battle during the filming of
the second season as Ries and mes
blanketed sir Christian's troops and
dragon flame two other dragons Rose into
the sky Aon on vagar and King a gone
himself on the gleaming Sunfire to her
credit rainy didn't flee Dragon fought
dragons and a second sun blossomed in
the sky if you watch all of my videos
then you already know I've been
documenting most of their filming on set
and out on location the journey began
way back in May of 2022 when ranian
intelligence first announced that HBO
had renewed House of the Dragon for a
second season already at that time not
even the first episode of the first
season was out which showed the great
confidence the company had in the series
the show was then officially renewed in
August of 2022 when the First episodes
were releasing on HBO and HBO Max they
started working on the second season
back in January of this year the first
leg of filming was at Leeson Studios and
Spain now if you remember that was when
they were filming scenes for Jaris and
melee's funeral ceremonies out in the
streets of Kings Landing afterwards
filming then went back to leavesden
studios in England where among other
things they filmed the infamous blood
and cheese scene also to add to that
later ranian discovered that the first
episode of the new season would be named
a son for a son most of you should
already know exactly what that means if
you've seen my videos or Red Fire and
Blood House of the Dragon will have a
very bloody second season as we head
into the heart of the dance of the
Dragons now the second leg of filming
was in Wales this was where we saw a lot
of the scenes with the new dragon Zeds
on Dragon Stone as well as getting our
first glimpse of members of house valyon
most recently we saw the Third Leg of
filming was out in Bourne Woods as they
were shooting scenes for the incredible
battle at rook's rest this major
historical battle will involve many of
the Heavy Hitters from House of the
Dragon most notably sir Christen Cole
aegon and Amon Targaryen as well as
rainy Targaryen and their dragons this
will most likely be the bloodiest battle
in the season it will without a doubt be
one of the biggest highlights in the
show it will also be one of the saddest
as well well because both the blacks and
the greens will suffer heavy losses from
the battle if you followed my videos
during the filming of these scenes then
you know that will be men screaming and
soldiers burned alive as the dragons
unleash their fiery hell from above the
battle at rook's rest will be a better
episode than the Field of Fire we saw in
Game of Thrones when Daenerys attacked
the Lannister Army now besides this
major battle we also saw some of the
silverhair Targaryen girls one of the
locals on set actually described this
scene as one of the targ and girls
falling down my guess is it's due to her
heartbreak when she realizes what
happened during the battle and finally
filming went back to leaves in studios
to finish whatever scenes they had left
among many things they filmed scenes
with the sea snake ship as well as night
scenes in King's Landing with the men
from the city watch as I said at the
beginning of this video now all of the
new footage will be handed over to the
editors and special effects team this
should mean that we will be getting our
first official teaser within the next
few months
now I don't expect us to actually see a
full official trailer until much later
most likely in the spring as always I
will be here to update you on everything
that's happening behind the scenes at
HBO I'll also make sure to inform you on
any new information that is released
regarding Game of Thrones other shows
like the series about Duncan egg or Jon
Snow now that the strikes are ending we
should be getting some new updates about
those shows very soon make sure you
subscribe so you will be the first to
know whenever I release a new video once
again I I have to thank all of you for
watching another one of my videos I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon
[Music]
bye
for